SPEAKER 1: So what
we're going to do
is just have a
really brief panel.
We're going to ask them to
introduce themselves and tell
a little bit about their story.
I have like one
or two questions.
But really, this
is about you asking
the questions that are
interesting to you.
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH: Hi,
I'm Anselm Baird-Smith.
I was actually--
despite my name,
I'm French, raised in France.
I did my studies
here in a school
I'm very glad to be able to do
some advertising for [FRENCH]
Institut superieur
d'Electronique de Paris.
And that was computer science.
This was back in the
days, unfortunately.
After that, I did a PhD
at Paris VI Jussieu.
And after this, I pretty much
went more or less directly
to California.
So we're in '97.
Sun Microsystems was the
place to be at that time.
So I went to Sun Microsystems.
Sun Microsystems
invited me to join them.
And after three
years there, I felt
like I didn't come to Silicon
Valley to be in a big company.
So I figured I should join
the start up, which I did.
Irony turns out that
real names [INAUDIBLE]
very first company
that actually did
a commercial deal
is Google in '99.
After this-- so
this company failed
for all sorts of reasons.
I then went to do my own
company, Distributed Database,
which was a massive failure.
We spent a year
writing software.
And we realized by
the end of that year
that we had no customers,
which is kind of a problem.
So the VCs told us very
nicely that they would not
fund us anymore.
And then, I joined eBay.
EBay was the first
time I actually
ran a consumer website.
And that was fascinating to me.
One of my [INAUDIBLE]
things was to actually--
I implemented the spell
checker for descriptions
of eBay items, which
is probably something
that if you've got
an eBay item, you'll
know what I mean by this, the
vocabulary in eBay descriptions
in listings.
After another two
years at eBay, this guy
at Sun that I had worked
with several years
before told me that I should
meet with some other guy
and have lunch with
him, which I did.
And this guy convinced
me over lunch
that I should do this
startup with him.
And he promised me that if
I joined him, I'd be CTO.
It'd be awesome.
He'd get some money,
and that we'll
have an office in two weeks,
all of which became true,
literally.
I called my wife
after I had lunch.
I said, I'm leaving eBay.
She was not happy.
I did leave eBay.
And literally, that was June 15.
On July 1, we had offices
in Palo Alto, $10 million
in the bank, and we
were ready to fly.
MICHEL MUNIE: So I started
out-- I lived in Chicago.
I went to the
University of Illinois.
I did math and computer
science for undergrad.
I also came out to California.
However, I was sure that I
was going to be an academic,
and I was going to do
nothing useful purposefully.
I wanted to be very academic.
So I went to Stanford.
I got a PhD.
Around the end of the PhD,
as is natural in California,
I got involved in a startup.
So I started a startup with
my advisor and my office mate.
We raised money from
Kleiner Perkins.
And so our idea was that
maybe 10 years ago, or maybe
15 years ago, Yahoo had
organized the web manually.
And then after that,
Google came along
and did this wonderful job
algorithmically saying,
we're not going to
have a directory
structure of the internet.
We're going to have algorithms.
And it's going to be better.
And it's going to
be more efficient.
And your life will be nice.
And we had a similar idea.
We thought we'd do something
for your friends in social.
Like right now,
Facebook is essentially
a directory structure.
Google+ is a
directory structure.
Twitter is just a list.
And you can do something more.
And you can make
people better friends,
and I think better people.
So we worked on that.
We had some
interesting technology
and got to work with
great investors.
And then also, we had a
conversation with Google.
At the time, it
was Vic Gundotra.
And we had dinner with him.
And something very
similar happened.
Soon after that,
we were acquired.
I've been at Google for
almost two years now.
MARTIN GORNER: So
hi, I'm Martin.
Most of you know me
by now because I also
organized this event with all
of the amazing speakers that
joined us today.
So thanks to all of them.
And yes, actually,
I spent two years
at STMicroelectronics
freshly out of college
in Bristol in the UK.
Right after that, I joined
a startup called Mobipocket.
And this startup was then
something that was strange.
And some people even
told us that it was evil.
We wanted to make
books electronic.
So we were, in 2000, when
e-books were kind of hot--
because at that point,
Microsoft invested in the idea.
And we pioneered e-books on PDAs
at that point, so PalmPilots,
pocket PCs, and so on.
This ran I can't
say successfully.
But it ran.
There were people
who were telling us
that what we were
doing was useless.
Publishers were mostly telling
us that what we were doing
was evil, that we
would destroy culture.
What they meant
by that is that we
were disrupting their
existing business model.
But when you talk
to a publisher,
he calls that,
"destroying culture."
But on the other hand, we also
had users where [INAUDIBLE].
I remember in those
days, reading on a PDA
was not so easy.
We didn't have retina
screens in those days.
We had one sci-fi series
that had 16 volumes.
For some reason, we didn't get
the rights to volume number 16.
And we had complaints,
people who read all the 15
volumes on their
shitty PalmPilot PDA.
And they were complaining,
where is volume 16?
So it was engaging, definitely.
But it wasn't a bang,
nothing like that.
And then, something very bad
happened-- the smartphone.
So PDAs died because
phones became PDAs.
But phones, if you
remember at that time,
had screens even smaller
than a PalmPilot.
And the first smartphones
had these postage stamp
sized screens where reading
was completely impossible.
It's challenging on
a PalmPilot, but it's
completely impossible on one of
those Nokias of the early days.
And so even our not so
great business when boom.
But they still believed in it.
And, well, it just happened
that around 2005, Amazon
had this crazy idea that they
would change their business
model from physical books
to electronic books.
And they started shopping
around for someone
who had the technology.
And we happened to have the
technology, the technology
for creating the books, the
file format, the distribution,
the catalog, the reading
technology on mobile devices--
the whole set.
There was nothing, so we
had to do the whole set.
And we were happy enough
to b acquired by Amazon
to actually make the Kindle.
And it's funny.
Nobody here talks about the
post-acquisition experience,
which-- I talked
with all of you guys,
and it was pretty
terrible for all of us.
So I know that all of you are
dreaming of being acquired.
But be warned.
Being acquired is the
end of your startup.
You'll get money to walk away.
Or you'll get money, you'll
work on something else
in the company where
you were acquired.
Don't dream of becoming
the new VP of the company
because you had this
idea, you were acquired,
and you will become
super important at Apple.
That doesn't happen.
SPEAKER 1: So I was going
to ask you about timing.
I think a lot of startups fail
or succeed based on timing,
like a lot of
companies in general.
You talked about the PalmPilot
going away, coming back.
If you had somehow foreseen
smartphones and created
that-- but it still worked out
in a lot of the situations.
So for yourself, what
do you think right now,
if you're speaking
to this audience,
would be apt timing for them?
What trends would you suggest
that they look towards
to create great applications?
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH: That's
a very stupid question.
If I knew, I might be on
the other side of the stage.
The one thing I'd say is
timing is of the essence.
I mentioned this failed company.
It was just too early.
It was a little bit--
really, I'm biased.
But the supper was great.
The concept of having the
database that could fail
wasn't-- 2,000
people [INAUDIBLE].
They had those
transactions, and they
didn't want
[INAUDIBLE] too soon.
By the same token,
at Lala, we started
with CD trading, a CD--
that is, a plastic thing.
And basically, what we did
is we let people exchange
CDs over postal mail.
And the one thing I
will say about timing
is it's of the essence.
And if you don't hit it
right, you will fail.
And the best way to figure
out if you had it right
is to check if you have users.
So CD trading was
an awesome idea.
And it took a year for
us to realize it actual
was not anymore the right
time to deal with CDs.
And we moved into digital
music very quickly.
So the one thing I
will say about timing
is get ready to adjust.
Change-- if you have a
sense that the time is not
right for your product--
too late, too soon-- adjust,
change.
There's a time for everything.
And it really,
really helps if you
[INAUDIBLE] right
timing [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: So you talk
about your advisor,
so having an advisor.
And he kind of
convinced you to go
to the direction of a startup.
My question was, would you
have gone that direction
after your PhD without him?
And how do you
suggest these guys
find that person, that
advisor, that mentor,
that kind of experienced,
seasoned entrepreneur?
MICHEL MUNIE: Yeah,
good question.
I think the most
important thing for people
you work with-- if you've done
a PhD, it takes a long time.
So I had a long time to
work with my advisor,
and also my office mate.
We started on the
exact same day.
We went to all the college
visits for graduate school
at the same time.
So I'd known these people
for about seven years.
And I think that more
than anything else, having
reliable people that you can
count on is really important.
Because there's lots of times
where you will be in conflict.
Essentially, it's a
changing landscape.
People come in with
different opinions.
If you don't have
successful ways of resolving
these different opinions
to this conflict,
then I think a startup
will just fall apart.
So being able to do
business with people
that you know very well, and
you've worked with in the past,
is fantastic.
Also related to that is that
my advisor had done startups
before, which I would
highly recommend.
If this is your first
startup, then hopefully you're
working with someone who
it's not their first startup.
I think that there's
certainly a trend.
Investors notice this-- is that
they invest in companies that
have one of their founders who's
had a successful exit before.
[INAUDIBLE].
MARTIN GORNER: Or unsuccessful.
MICHEL MUNIE: Or
unsuccessful, [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
it's interesting.
There's always this
talk of failure.
And I think failure is
obviously not a bad thing.
But there's a really
interesting blog
by Joe Kraus, who's a
partner in Google Ventures.
And the blog post talks about
how failure is a good thing
to get under your belt.
But a trend is
success over and over,
and that they often
follow those founders.
So even for yourself,
finding people
who have been
successful in the past
is a great way to at least
learn what that feels like.
Martin, my question is, since
these two guys over here
are talking about
Silicon Valley,
and they started their
big startups over there,
what do you think
about for these guys?
Do they need to go
to Silicon Valley?
Can they stay in France?
What's your recommendation
for startups
trying to make it here?
MARTIN GORNER: So first, I
will quote my former boss
at Mobipocket who famously said
that he was stupid and idiotic
for having founded
his company in Paris.
He said that of himself,
so I can say it.
And that was in 2000.
And I think a lot of
things have changed.
And he was talking specifically
about the bureaucrats.
And I've seen a study
last month where
someone did a study of
the bureaucracy you need
to go through in each of
the European countries
started a startup.
And surprisingly,
that study said--
it's not me-- that France was
number one, bureaucracy wise.
Personally, I prefer Paris
to the Silicon Valley.
But that's just a
personal opinion.
And I guess many of
you here do as well.
I like [INAUDIBLE]
as well, I can
spend a couple of
months in Berlin.
There is a lot going on there.
London is fantastic
for startups.
So I definitely think there's
a lot to do here in Europe.
Where we are still
lacking a little bit
is that it's said to be
easier to get financing,
and especially
serious financing,
like a second round of
financing, in Silicon Valley.
Because private
investment is more
developed there than it is here.
On the other side, since
I've heard that information,
I also heard that
it wasn't true.
Because competition
was fierce with those
available VCs in the Valley.
So community and the
quality of engineers I think
are good here.
And there is something
to be said also
about going to the Valley
for the experience, the PC
environment, and the innovation
with the other startups.
But in the end,
it's your choice.
But I don't think
there is a bad choice.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I'm Greg.
I'm working on the [INAUDIBLE]
device around bicycles.
It's just the beginning.
And I have a question.
You said that failure is-- you
wouldn't probably face failure.
Do we have to fail on purpose
to get on the second startup
the attention of VCs,
and say, nice story
about, I failed, and I stood
up again, and everything?
MICHEL MUNIE: I think succeeding
is better than failing.
Yeah, the thing that
I was surprised--
and maybe I shouldn't be
surprised by this at all--
is that they were
all really smart.
All the VCs I talked to,
I was impressed by them.
They are more on the
people side of things.
And they don't always
understand the intricacies
of the technology.
But they really are
experts at their field.
And they've had a
long track record
of being good at what they do.
And I think what they've noticed
is that people who succeed
continue to succeed.
And maybe this is not
a brilliant insight.
But they're not
going to be won over
by some story or
some background.
They really want
typical things that you
need to see before
investing in a business.
What are the backgrounds
of the people?
What's their track record?
Do they have the skills
to execute on this?
Do they have a vision?
Will their vision make money?
How will they exit?
They're looking at basic things.
And I would focus
on these basics
before you think about any
way to, I guess I would say,
game the system.
MARTIN GORNER: And what
I said about failure
is know that failure is good.
But here, failure is
regarded as a stigma-- you
failed, you're a
failure, you know?
That is not the case.
You can talk with people who
are serial entrepreneurs.
They tell you, I've
done this, and this,
and I've done this as well.
And you ask them, how did it go?
Oh, it all failed.
But now, I'm doing this.
And it's great.
It's great.
And the fourth
thing might succeed.
You look at someone like--
well, the famous example
is Richard Branson.
He did so many shaky
businesses before he actually
started his recording business.
And he had success
there because he
found one artist that
actually became successful.
And from there, he went
on to do the whole rest
of the Virgin empire.
So the message was just,
failing is not a stigma.
Failing is experience.
AUDIENCE: Hi,
[INAUDIBLE], a new way
to take notes in a
more smarter way.
So each one of you, could you
give me your number one advice
with your greatest
startup experience.
MARTIN GORNER:
OK, so I'll start.
And it's going to
be very different.
In my experience, it was
believing in what we did
and sticking to it against
all odds, which usually, you
are told not to do.
You are told to
[INAUDIBLE] and so on.
We had all these people
telling us how bad we were
and how useless our
product was and how
it was going to destroy
the Earth and whatever.
And we still kept going.
So we kind of knew
that e-books were
going to be electronic at
one point in time, anyway.
That was our inside knowledge.
And we stuck to it.
MICHEL MUNIE: Yeah, what
you said resonates a lot.
Just to add-- extreme
optimism in the face
of a high probability of
failure is very important.
But I think for--
it's OK, though.
I think you actually
need these two mindsets.
My personal advice for you
would be, launch sooner.
Whatever you're
planning on launching,
you need to get it
out there sooner.
And this is really
easy advice to ignore.
Because there's always
good reasons not to launch.
There's plenty of good
reasons not to launch.
But you should launch sooner.
Whatever you're planning,
if you haven't launched yet,
this is a really bad situation.
Because you don't have any
feedback on how you're doing.
So launch.
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH:
What Michel said
before is [INAUDIBLE]
people who he's worked with.
Amazingly enough, the
distributed [INAUDIBLE]
I mentioned earlier,
it was my best friend.
We ended up in
pretty rough shape.
We've since then mended
the relationship.
And by [INAUDIBLE],
we sold Lala,
which was the successful
one, I [INAUDIBLE]
had literally learned at lunch.
And I was extremely
lucky that we
were a particular mix of people,
and that the relationship
will grow.
That helps you go through
all the other problems
that I just mentioned.
You'll be getting press.
You're going to want
to launch sooner.
You are you going to want
to [INAUDIBLE] and all
of those things if you have
good friends that you can work
with through all these
issues, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: Hello, [INAUDIBLE]--
I work in an organization that
finances startups and
entrepreneurs in Paris.
I do have a question
about timing.
Your two examples are
quite interesting.
In your case, you
say that you have
to believe in what you did,
and that actually, you waited.
But eventually, it worked.
About the question pertaining
is that, yeah, it works.
Sometimes, it's not good timing.
So when you see it
doesn't work, you
should just get out
as soon as possible.
So I think it's often a
question for startups,
how long, or until when, do
I believe in my business,
and how can I understand
that actually it's
not working, because
there's no market?
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH: That's
such a good question.
My answer is very simple--
half of your funding,
half of your funding.
So if you do your first run,
when you have half that amount
in the bank account, that's the
time to have a reality check.
So I'll keep it at that.
But you have to have very
objective [INAUDIBLE].
It's really, really hard
to give up on something
you've spent so
much patience into.
It's just really hard to
decide that it's not working
and it's time to adjust--
half of your funding.
MARTIN GORNER: So in
my case, the funding--
I'm not going to say
it wasn't a problem.
The funding was a problem.
But we were operating
at such a small scale.
We were a microscopic company.
Actually, we were at
a maximum of 17 people
at the height of the web bubble.
And in late 2000, so like
fall, 2000, the VCs said,
shut it down, we're
walking out, and so on.
We fired everyone with
remaining only five engineers.
And from there on, we
sailed, but on a slow pace.
So the founders would
find some money.
And we started making some
money, a little revenue,
which was kind of
enough to get us
through the five years
of slow-pace sailing.
So we didn't have that
reality check time--
we are out of money, what
do we do now, you know?
In our case, the
real reality check
was that we had
customers-- not many.
But those customers seemed to
be practically engaged with us.
They were paying customers.
They were paying an average
$10 per book, so not pennies,
but $10 for every book.
And they were coming
for more books.
We didn't have enough of them.
We didn't have the
numbers we wanted.
But those who were in, those
who we managed to convince,
they were convinced.
They wanted more.
So that's kind of
what got us going.
We had this small but very,
very believing and active
customer base.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
My company does [INAUDIBLE].
And it does a lot
of different things
mainly with streaming
video on the internet.
And my question is
one for one of you.
I normally believe
that you got acquired
because a dinner went nice.
And my question
would be, why exactly
was your company acquired?
Is it because you had
great clients, just
great technology, a
mix of everything?
What was exactly your
precise reasoning
you got acquired by giants?
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH: So in our
case, we had a very good exit,
I should say-- let's be
clear, a very financial exit.
And we were lucky enough to have
several people fighting for us.
I think the reason they
were quite impressed
is because they were
afraid of others having us.
And so that was the case.
Because we were clearly
on the ramp up with users.
All the [INAUDIBLE]
were going up.
And so Apple was worried that
somebody else would get us,
and it was a good place to be.
But I want to point
out that we never, ever
worked to being acquired.
We always worked toward building
the best products-- always,
consistently, always on
building the best products.
MICHEL MUNIE: It's
a good question.
I think one of the
most important things
is that you need to think
about why you're doing this.
So some of the
advice I got early on
is it's better to be a
missionary than a mercenary.
And it's kind of
like a funny thing.
But if you're in it
just for the exit--
not saying that you shouldn't
think about that ever.
But if you're in it, you'll
be kind of an unhappy person.
I personally think
this is true, is
that you need to
consider things not
just in the context of business,
but in the context of life.
And the reason
that I worked on it
is because I believe
in the mission.
And I think acquisitions have a
lot of different factors going
into it.
But companies do
recognize people
who are in it with true passion.
And I think a lot
of the times, that's
what they look for in addition
to passion from the users.
And so my advice about
acquisition in general
is keep your eyes
on the true target.
Don't even really think
about acquisition.
MARTIN GORNER: Well, in our
case, it was, I would say,
lower key than that.
So Amazon had this
[INAUDIBLE] business,
had this idea that he
wanted his book business
to become an e-book business.
And that's something that he
promised his shareholders.
Because Amazon at that
time was a book seller.
And everybody kind
of had this idea
that physical goods one day or
the other, especially cultural
goods, are going digital.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Mathieu
from [INAUDIBLE].
Martin, just before
you said it was
difficult to accept that we
were acquired by the giant.
And don't you want to
create a new startup?
MARTIN GORNER: Sure.
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH:
It's actually, I'll say,
interesting.
The majority of founders
that Google acquires,
and a lot of the founders that
come to Google after starting
a startup, a majority of them,
so above 50%, stay at Google.
And probably because they
let us have a lot of freedom
to have our own
internal startup.
MARTIN GORNER: So actually, my
startup was acquired by Amazon.
And what happened is I
was one of the-- well,
the first engineer
at that startup.
I wasn't the founder.
I was the first engineer.
What happened is that after
the acquisition, of course,
the founders left as soon as the
contract allowed them to leave.
It's always like that.
And you get this clause
in the acquisition saying,
you have to stay for
a year and a half.
And they negotiate the close
so that it's only half a year.
And then, you leave
as soon as you can.
I don't know why, but
that's always what happens.
And then, Amazon asked me to be
the CEO of that startup, which
now was a subsidiary.
So that's kind of the reason
I stayed a couple of years
at Amazon.
Because at that time, it
was a challenge for me.
And I liked that challenge.
Then, I came over to Google.
I did something completely
different-- developer
relations.
So I see a lot of startups.
And I love the
innovation that I see
and all the energy
that is out there.
Of course, it's tempting.
But I can't say here on a video
that my boss will actually
watch that I'm
thinking about leaving.
MICHEL MUNIE: I've got
to answer this one too?
OK, so do I want to
do something else?
I think the answer is,
eventually, I will.
But you know, life
is pretty long.
And I'm very happy
where I am right now.
So the biggest difference
is-- or two big differences--
one is surprising,
one probably isn't.
So the surprising one is that
I learned way more at Google
than I did at the startup.
So at the startup, I
learned very little
about very many things.
But overall, it wasn't a lot.
If you added all my
learnings into a bucket,
it was just a whole bunch of
random crap-- a little bit
about PR, a little
bit about marketing,
a little bit about programming,
a little bit about databases,
a little bit about algorithms.
I feel like at Google now,
I'm working on something
that i care a lot about.
So I did my PhD.
I'm working on algorithms now.
I do recommendation systems.
The amount of data we
have here is amazing.
I really enjoy this.
So I'm going to stay probably
for quite a long time.
The second thing, which
is the obvious one,
is that I don't have existential
stress in my life anymore.
I used to wake up and
worry about the company
and about the people
who were working there.
Because I knew if I screwed
up, the company would be over,
like you have to go in
someday and tell these people,
we're out of money, I'm laying
you guys off, that's it.
And this is, I think, a very
stressful situation to be in,.
And maybe it's exciting, too.
But right now, I
feel like I focus
on what I do not like
some abstract-- not
some bad result that will
come from my actions.
This is because I believe
in the mission of Google,
to organize the
world's information,
make it universally
accessible and useful.
I really do believe in this.
I think this is a good
thing for the world.
I think it's made the
world a better place.
And I don't worry about Google's
financial health, either.
So I can come in.
I can work towards that
mission and do the kind of work
I enjoy doing every day.
ANSELM BAIRD-SMITH: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
gentlemen all for joining us,
and you guys all
for coming today.
We really appreciate your time.
[APPLAUSE]